en france le grand projet du tgv
méditerranée reliant en 3h paris à
marseille prend corps avec aujourd'hui
l'installation d'une infrastructure
pharaonique un immense viaduc de 2400
tonnes qui a pris sa place en roulant
littéralement sur l'eau romuald de
bonnans frédéric basket c'est un drôle
d'animal un géant d'acier de 2400 tonnes
peu des hommes lilliputiens se sont mis
en tête de dompter installions
ferroviaire entre les deux berges d'un
fleuve
rien de plus simple en apparence mais
ici il a fallu déjouer la puissance des
eaux du rhône et la violence du mistral
impossible de construire sur place alors
les ingénieurs ont eu une idée bien
saugrenue
une fois assemblée le monstre de métal
est arrivé en roulant sur l'eau une
première réalisée par guidage
informatique à la vitesse de 200 mètres
à l'heure le système est contrôlé par
visée laser
c'était une visée laser nous permet
d'ajuster la trajectoire au centimètre
près toutes les informations sont
transmises à l'informatique et aux
hommes aux opérateurs bien sûr un qui
pilote tout ça est bien ce qui nous a
permis d'accoster très vite un ouvrage
d'art sera construit tous les 600 mètres
en conciliant parfois l'inconciliable
comme ici près d'avignon
élever un double pont monumentale sur
plus de trois kilomètres
un viaduc capable de supporter le
croisement de deux rames tgv 1600 tonnes
lancé à 300 km heure le tout au coeur
d'une zone à rona défense devant dans la
phase chantier jusqu'à 200 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est calculé pour résister à ce
type devant on a également les problèmes
sismique liée à la région et on a pris
comme comme seuil d'études une marge
très confortable par rapport aux
éventualités sismique connu
historiquement sur la faille de nîmes
des ducs technologique
bien loin du charme du vieux pont
d'avignon